In order to talk about what's
going on in network protocols,
it helps to have a bit
of a visual language.
Just as we might use a line graph
to depict a financial trend or
a histogram to show the distribution of
a variable, there's a particular kind of
chart that's useful for
illustrating network protocols.
It's called a sequence diagram and
here's an example.
This is a diagram of an HTTP
connection using keep-alive.
These two lines on the left and
right are timelines, with time
advancing from the top to the bottom.
The line on the left represents
the client's view of the world.
The line on the right is
the server's view of the world.
And these arrows between
them represent messages sent
from the client to the server or
from the server to the client.
You'll sometimes see them drawn at an
angle, which serves to remind you that
messages are never instantaneous,
there's always latency or
lag time between when the client sends
something and the server receives it or
vice versa.
But conventionally,
they're drawn straight and
we just have to remember that
time never goes backwards.
Now because we haven't
invented time travel,
anything that either end
does at any point in time,
can only be affected by things
that that end has already seen.
Like if the client sends two requests
and the server starts responding to
the first one as soon as it sees it,
the server can't
change its first response on
the basis of the second request.
It hasn't seen that second one yet.
Sequence diagrams remind us
to keep things in order and
to make sure that our notions of
what's going on in the network
don't assume that servers
can see the future.
So, here's what's going
on in this diagram.
The client since an HTTP GET request
with a connection keep alive header.
The server sends a response and
once a client has received that response
it can send another request over
the same connection and so on.
Here's the thing, though,
a sequence diagram always represents
some particular level of a protocol.
Like here's a diagram for
just one request at the HTTP layer
with a HTTP GET and a response.
But this doesn't show
individual IP packets.
And I assure you that if that response
is a download of a six megabyte file,
it's not going to happen as simply
as just one arrow suggests.
When we look deeper into the stack,
we'll find that one exchange on
the HTTP level may be a shorthand for
a bunch of exchanges on a lower level.
In fact, let's take a closer
look at that right now.